joe biden is basically preemptively
declaring victory
he's not saying that he definitely won't
be saying yeah we're going to win so
here was joe biden yesterday
walking out to the cheers presumably of
the members of the media
declaring that they were on track to win
the presidential
election now
after a long night of counting it's
clear
that we're winning enough states to
reach 270 electoral votes needed to win
the presidency
i'm not here to declare that we've won
but i am here to report when the count
is finished
we believe we will be the winners okay
so um
that is not helpful in any way shape or
form it's also not helpful because
the fact of the matter is there are
still votes to be counted in arizona
so this morning the arizona republic
reported that trump is actually getting
the share of votes he would need to
reclaim arizona
according to the arizona republic
azcentral.com
as maricopa county released the results
from 140 000 more ballots on wednesday
night and thursday morning
president donald trump received almost
the exact share he would need to charge
back to win
arizona's 11 electoral votes and
potentially re-election trump won the
batches of ballots from maricopa county
counted wednesday
and early thursday by a roughly 57-40
margin over former vice president joe
biden
those votes likely early ballots sent to
the county on monday and tuesday
narrowed biden's lead over trump in
arizona to 68 thousand votes
his lead had been more than 90 000 votes
earlier on wednesday
paul benson republican pollster with the
consulting firm highground said trump
needs to win 56. 57.6
of the 470 thousand votes the arizona
republic estimates remain
to be counted he said that's almost
exactly what he got in the first patch
he could do it the problem for trump is
he needs to replicate that performance
across all of the remaining 470 000
votes left to count in the state
he needs to do it across all of
arizona's 15 diverse counties that
includes
pima coconino coconino and santa cruz
counties
trump needs to repeat that permanence
with every single batch every single
ballot every single day said bent
the first step in the long journey was a
successful rum in
a successful one in trump's tightrope
walk
president trump also needs to maintain
that vote margin through different
batches of ballots that include those
that arrived in the mail before election
day early ballots dropped off at the
polls on election day
and provisional ballots voters cast
because they didn't have the right form
of identification
or they went to the wrong polling place
but this means that there is a pathway
that is still open in arizona and this
is giving everybody over at fox news
heartburn and it should give everybody
over fox news heartburn because you'll
recall
that very very early on tuesday night
fox news called arizona in favor of joe
biden
and it really shifted the momentum of
what everybody was feeling because it
came
shortly after florida had been called
for trump and it looked like trump was
running away
with florida now does that impact the
vote not really
okay there's some speculation that
perhaps the call in arizona came so
early that there were a few people
who were left in line that theoretically
could be a problem
but i believe the call didn't come like
five minutes in it came probably an hour
and a half after arizona actually closed
the polls an hour after arizona closed
the polls
so my guess is you're not talking about
thousands and thousands of people who
are left in line just to be perfectly
accurate about all of this
with that said fox news calling it early
was seen by a lot of people including a
lot of conservatives as a sign that fox
news wants to get away from trump just
generally
and it caused an awful lot of
consternation on fox news a trump
campaign official yesterday
reamed fox news for the early arizona
call
as this narrows there is going to be
great pressure on you guys
to be honest with you fox news to
rescind your call it was
it was a premature call you know we were
livid about the fact that you and then
the ap
made that call there are seven
organizations that call states on
election night from time to time
seven five of those seven did not make
that call
okay we got it and i agree we don't want
to be in a position
this is going to lead john biden to
falsely declare himself the president
elect at some point understood okay so
this one there's a lot of pressure on
fox news
and uh you can see it actually on the
ground msnbc was reporting on a crowd
yesterday
outside some of the maricopa county
offices where the votes were being
counted
shouting fox news sucks right which is
not something that you normally hear
from crowds
of republican voters here's a little bit
of that footage
a loud and very boisterous crowd you'll
start here and then
start up here
and they're actually chanting fox news
sucks fox news sucks the reason why
they're chanting that is because
fox news called arizona for
biden yesterday and a lot of people
are angry about that msnbc guy's like
this is amazing
they're not shouting at me that's
amazing
probably the best clip from last night
was actually rachel maddow
when it finally dawned on her that trump
could actually win arizona because
remember the map is such that if trump
wins arizona
and he wins pennsylvania remember the
votes are still being counted in
pennsylvania
guess who wins the election and so this
dawns on rachel maddow in real time and
steve kornacki who actually is quite
good at his job
is going through the stats and uh you
can see rachel maddow almost begins to
collapse in on herself
if things go this this way we are
looking at something that looks very
close to a tie
yeah and i i would just i'd say it at
this point because it's 75 000 out of
000 and change that are going to come in
so we're not sure it's exactly going to
be 59
when all is said and done if it ends up
at 55 i think he'll be short
if it ends up at 65 i think there's a
chance he would overtake biden there
so we haven't really established the
rate what we've established right now is
the possibility
okay and rachel maddow then starts to
almost fall apart
and it's it's it's pretty fantastic okay
meanwhile ron desantis the governor of
florida
he rhema fox news as well so they should
you guys need to retract the call i mean
fox news was under heavy pressure for
the last 48 hours to retract a call that
obviously was premature
so here's ron desantis going after fox
news trump is
gaining in arizona there's probably 500
so here's my thing sean if you're going
to be quick on the trigger
then be quick on the trigger for both
sides and stand by it but it seems like
with trump
they never want to call the state and
then biden man they'll do it right away
it's inconsistent it's unacceptable and
look
north carolina should be called for the
president uh
for sure arizona that fox should rescind
that call
well meanwhile nate silver is saying the
same thing so this is not just
republican partisans like members of the
trump campaign
or ron desantis the governor of florida
and he's making a good point there too
which is it took them four
damned ever to call florida on election
night i mean it took like four hours for
them to call florida even though we all
knew within the first hour because all
of the ballots were already in and were
counted very very quickly
florida has a very smooth because of
2000 tabulation system
they really come out with excellent
voter data very quickly it took them
forever to call that state but arizona
they were really quick on the trigger
and he's right about that nate silver
said
i don't know i guess i'd say that biden
will win arizona if you force me to pick
but i sure as heck don't think the state
should have been called by anyone i
think the calls that were previously
made should be retracted now
that's nate silver so there's a lot of
heartburn out there
for people who think that this election
is already over it is worth noting here
by the way that georgia may end up in
the democratic lane that's how close all
of these states are so there's still
votes coming in in fulton county which
includes atlanta
it is quite possible that those votes
split in favor of joe biden
which means that joe biden would end up
winning georgia so you could see a
situation in which
trump loses the election because he
loses georgia buddy wins arizona and
pennsylvania so
there's still a lot of outstanding
questions as to where
this race is right now plus there are
now lawsuits that are on the books so
anybody who's declaring that the race is
over
anybody who's declaring that this this
election is done not yet it ain't